ukraine's president addressed the
security council on the heels of his
visit to bucha vladimir zelinski called
for the united nations to hold russia
accountable for war crimes saying its
credibility is at
stake ladies and gentlemen are you ready
to shut down the u.n
do you believe that the times of
international law have passed away
if your answer is no then actions are
needed now immediate actions are needed
the un charter must get its force back
again immediately the u.n system must be
reformed immediately so that the right
of the veto will not become the right of
death
he told of horrors at the hands of
russian troops including women being
raped and killed in front of families
people in cars being run over by tanks
and he showed grisly images of dead
bodies and civilian clothes laying in
the streets but russia insisted the
images were staged
we are not shooting against civilian
targets in order to save as many
civilians as possible precisely why
we're not advancing as fast as many
expected we're not acting like americans
and their allies in iraq and syria
raising entire cities to the ground they
have no pity for them but we felt great
pity because these people are close to
us
the united states called for russia's
removal from the human rights council
which has begun a commission of inquiry
in ukraine
given the growing mountain of evidence
russia should not have a position of
authority in a body whose purpose
whose very purpose
is to promote
respect for human rights
not only is this the height of hypocrisy
it is dangerous
the u.n secretary general warned that
the rising cost of food and fuel as a
result of the crisis made 74 developing
nations particularly vulnerable
we are already seeing some countries
move from vulnerability into crisis and
signs of serious social unrest
the flames of conflict are fooled by
inequality deprivation and underfunding
with all the warning sign signals
flashing red we have a duty to act
u.n officials pointed to growing
evidence of potential war crimes
primarily by russia and called for an
independent investigation
russia pointed to the united states and
its refusal to take part in an
investigation of its own soldiers in
afghanistan and showed no signs of
cooperating kristen salumi al-jazeera
the united nations